Paying off virtually everything that was set
up in the last 11 years of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, Avengers: Endgame truly feels like
the culmination of the 21 films that preceded
it.
The filmmaking team achieves this by tying
up tiny stories, calling back movies they
released years ago, and confirming lots of
fan theories.
And then Marvel execs took it one step further
by including basically everyone who's ever
starred in an MCU movie and giving them a
role in Endgame.
Case in point: That mysterious kid at the
end of the film that everyone is bending over
backwards to remember.
Warning: We're now entering spoiler county!
After the Avengers faced off against Thanos
and won, they assembled once more for a heartbreaking
reason: to attend the funeral of Tony Stark,
who sacrificed himself by snatching the Infinity
Stones away from the purple-faced despot,
then snapping his own fingers in order to
blast Thanos and his alien minions into oblivion.
The funeral scene begins with the heroes gathered
around Tony's beloved Pepper Potts and watching
a hologram message Tony recorded the day before
the Avengers traveled back in time to collect
the Stones.
It ends with a solemn sweeping shot of Tony's
closest friends watching his original arc
reactor float across the lake.
But a genuine pop-culture mystery has arisen
from all this melancholy:
"Freeze!
Don't move."
"You got me."
Audience members are having a hard time remembering
the brunette-haired teenage boy standing completely
alone at the funeral.
Who is he and how did he know Tony?
We have the answer for you: The character
was just a precocious young boy when he last
popped up in the Marvel Cinematic Universe…
way back in Iron Man 3.
He's Harley Keener, portrayed by actor Ty
Simpkins.
You may also recognize the actor from his
2015 appearance in Jurassic World.
If you can't recall, here's how Harley and
Tony first met: Searching for food, shelter,
and a place to recharge his suit, Tony breaks
into the garage of Harley's home in Rose Hill,
Tennessee.
The two characters form an unlikely but incredibly
sweet bond in the film.
Throughout his friendship with Harley, Tony
softens and reveals his fatherly side — a
side we also saw when he mentored Peter Parker
in Spider-Man: Homecoming.
When Iron Man 3 opened in theaters in 2013,
Simpkins was just 11 years old.
Now, he's 17, which explains why he looks
virtually unrecognizable in Avengers: Endgame.
Those who keep a finger on the pulse of all
things Marvel might not have been entirely
shocked to see Harley Keener make an appearance
in the film: Simpkins' casting was confirmed
way back in October of 2017.
Simpkins' physical appearance came as a bit
of a surprise though, since he's now a teenager
and not the tiny lad in Iron Man 3, but it
was never a secret that he was going figure
into Avengers: Endgame somehow
When news of Simpkins joining Avengers: Endgame
went public, fans wondered if Harley would
play a substantial role in the movie.
After Spider-Man disintegrated in Avengers:
Infinity War, some folks wondered if Keener
would step into his shoes and become Tony's
latest protege.
But others hit the nail on the head and predicted
exactly what ended up happening: Harley was
also a victim of the Decimation, and his involvement
in Endgame consisted solely of a brief, somewhat
confusing cameo.
Maybe he only had a few seconds of screen
time and no lines to deliver, but Harley's
appearance at Tony's funeral still made quite
an impact.
The MCU began with Iron Man over a decade
ago in 2008, and with the character's passing
in Avengers: Endgame, the superhero franchise
as we know it has come to an end.
It only makes sense that everyone who admired
Tony would attend his funeral to say goodbye…
even the young boy he met all those years
ago.
As much as Tony tried to resist friendship
and intimacy earlier in his life, he was clearly
loved by many.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.